[Music]
welcome to another episode of vm end to
end a show where we have a vm skeptic
and a vm enthusiast come together to
hash out all things vm related thanks
for being here today brian
happy to be here what's the topic for
today oh you know what it is i need to
know about identity i need to know about
access i want to know why i can't just
ssh and everything or if i can what do
you got for me brian
okay so uh a little quickie uh bit here
and then i'm gonna bring a guest in
because uh i don't know all the details
so
one you can just ssh in right like it's
a computer you've got a you know sh
works with keys so you've got you know a
key pair and it kind of works as like
when you have that token you can get
into any machine that the public keys on
um
and you can just manage those all
yourself if you've got a system to do
that but it can get to be a lot and get
quite complicated especially as your
organization gets larger
and we have a way to delegate the
creation of those keys to
google's identity infrastructure and
that is why i wanted to bring in emanuel
who's one of our colleagues uh who
focuses on identity and access
management welcome emmanuel
brian thank you for that amazing
introduction uh how are you today carter
yeah i'm doing well a little confused
but i think brian can tell you where my
trouble my struggles lie
so emanuel what's the um what's the high
level on identity and access management
in google cloud
brian that's a great question so let's
really go back and define what is iam
right so iam stands for identity and
access management and so what basically
that means is that you can delegate or
you can control who has access to what
resources in your google cloud account
okay so you can control who has
resources or who has access to what
resources who's setting that up
well so at first you need to set up a
domain and so there's a person that's
called the super admin so the super
admin goes into
the admin console and they set up your
domain um and so once they set up your
domain it automatically creates an
organization for you now the super admin
is a role who can do anything within the
admin portal so they can manage users uh
they can create groups um they can set
up multi-factor authentication they can
do all these things via the admin portal
so we've got this super admin and domain
and the thing i'm used to looking at the
most is projects like what's the
how do those connect
right and so a domain
one-to-one maps with an organization and
so if we think of projects projects sit
under
an organization and so you can really
think of an organization as the root
node within your gcp account and so with
the root note you can have things under
them like projects and folders
and then you can assign resources to
uh projects as well
oh
and then this this hierarchical
structure is what's used to give access
to different areas i take it absolutely
there you go
so then what about if uh i want a script
or something to access services i'm like
i want a script to access part of like
google cloud's resources for me like
what do i do then if you want an outside
application or workload to access things
within uh google cloud you can use
what's called a service account and
what's that so you can really think of a
service account as a special account
that's granted to
applications in order to be able to
interact with apis within google cloud
and so if we really want to kind of put
this in context let's look at a user
account right so if i'm a user and i
have access to uh google cloud i would
go via chrome to
the google cloud browser or website and
then i'll log in and so when i put in my
username and password i'm authenticated
after i'm authenticated i get to inherit
the permissions
or roles that are attached to a group
that i'm assigned to right but if i'm an
application
i can't do that i can't go and log into
google chrome so i would need a service
account in order to interact with apis
and services within google cloud
got it that makes sense so we have
um these kind of organization units that
give access to things if i'm a user i
can get in one way maybe i can ssh in
uh if i'm pro programs i can you know
connect to other apis via these service
accounts are there any other ways um
the programs get access
yeah so you have service accounts and
then you also have service account keys
right so
back in the day in way ways this past
right we
gave outside applications access to
workloads or resources in google cloud
using service account keys right but
service account keys are problematic uh
one of the things that make service
account keys really not a good choice um
if you're trying to really securely
build resources in google cloud is
because that they never end right there
they're legal they live on forever and
so service account keys if their leak
can cause a really major issue i mean so
whoever has access to your service
account keys in theory can impersonate a
service account and get access to all
the apis and all the features that are
attached to that service account
and then in addition to that uh this
causes a secret management issue right
so how do we manage uh these keys that
are just floating around so now you have
to come up with a secrets management
strategy in order to safeguard
and provide some type of peace of mind
around these service account keys
i never actually thought about some of
these downsides of service account keys
and i i like to say like these these
these things from the way distant past i
love that
um
your what you just talked about though
made me think
of something like it seems like service
accounts are used for resources within
google cloud
what if i have some service or outside
of google cloud that i want to
authenticate into
um is there any way to let google manage
that
well yeah so we can do that uh but let's
so let's say i'm using terraform right
so i want to build infrastructure within
google cloud using a tool called
terraform right so i can do that so
long ago in order for me to do that in
order for
the outside application terraform to
interact with resources in my google
cloud account i had to give it service
account keys right and so i would set up
terraform i would create a provider
block i would pass in my service account
keys and
the service account keys would
impersonate a service account within
google cloud right so that worked but
now i can build my resources but now i
have to manage that specific key so now
we can use what's called short-lived
credentials and i don't have to worry
about
managing these service account keys so
now if i want to build infrastructure
in uh google cloud using terraform i can
use short-lived credentials in order to
auto authenticate terraform with google
cloud
i love how excited you were to tell me
the more about these short-lived tokens
because they are that cool they really
are
um so thank you but all right so but now
to the question before
um
is it possible to uh
like
get this kind of
security or access to external workloads
well yeah so we also have a feature
that's called workload identity
federation and so if you have workloads
that are external or outside of google
cloud that have their own identity
provider you can authenticate using
these short-lived tokens and so what
happens is you have an application who
gets credentials from its identity
provider and then those credentials are
passed to
google's token service and google
turquoise service takes those
credentials uh creates an ephemeral
short-lived
token that it passes to the external
application and now the external
application can access
an impersonator service account within
google cloud
got it okay so we've got we've got a lot
of different kinds of access here right
so we've got like users service accounts
short lived tokens workload stuff
how do
um how do i decide you know which ones
of these to use in a given situation
i mean that's a great question so it all
depends right so if i'm a user and i
just have a outside uh application that
doesn't have an identity provider let's
say uh once again i'm using uh terraform
right i can use short-lived credentials
to authenticate that outside application
uh and impersonating a service account
within google cloud if i have a workload
that has an identity provider like let's
say i'm using aws for my identity
provider or i'm using on-premise active
directory or i'm using azure active
directory or let's even say i'm using
opta in those cases it would be best to
use workload identity federation so you
can dynamically generate keys
and not have to worry about manually
generating keys from like uh gcloud
command line or one of the other methods
and then all of this taps into i am
that's um actually that's awesome so
you've got a consistent way to look at
it that's super cool so if somebody
wants to dig in more on this
like where should they start
in order to get more information about
uh iem security best practices workload
identity federation short-lived
credentials you will go to
cloud.google.com
i am slash docs
so to recap and thank you so much
emanuel for coming in because i had
never heard of short-lived tokens i
never heard of workload identity
federation
um and i never really thought about some
of the downsides to even service
accounts in the long-lived static keys
so to recap would you say using iam is a
is a best practice maybe going forward
absolutely i think if you're working in
any
large organization
setting up iam using organizations is
really the best way to go now if you
wanted to just play around with google
cloud you could sign up with just your
gmail account but if you did that that
wouldn't give you access to all the
benefits of organizations right so if
you're at a large enterprise
organizations um to
invoke iam on your google cloud account
is the best way to go
wow so that's about all i learned so
much today about workload federation
short-lived tokens and more
brian thanks for bringing the manual on
i gotta give you props no thank you
emmanuel this was great
uh i appreciate you brian and carter
thank you guys for the opportunity yes
if you're listening at home leave a
comment with something you learned so i
learned about short-lived tokens
workload federation what's something
that you learned about thank you that's
all for this episode of vm end to end
[Music]
you